das bad ist schmutzig ich rufe jetzt die
rezeption an und werde mich beschweren
das geht so nicht
rezeption la playa wie kann ich ihnen
helfen rezeption la playa wie kann ich
ihnen helfen
wir haben gerade eingecheckt und sind in
unserem zimmer angekommen
es ist schmutzig und ich habe ein zimmer
mit blick aufs meer reserviert
das zimmer hat außerdem auch keinen
balkon
das geht so nicht ich werde eine
schlechte bewertung auf ferienspaß punkt
ch schreiben wenn sie uns nicht das
zimmer gebe dass sich reserviert habe
das geht so nicht ich werde eine
schlechte bewertung auf ferienspaß punkt
ch schreiben wenn sie uns nicht das
zimmer gebe dass sich reserviert habe
entschuldigen sie ich habe ihnen
wirklich ein falsches zimmer gegeben
ich schicke gleich jemanden vorbei sie
bekommen ein anderes zimmer
entschuldigen sie ich habe ihnen
wirklich ein falsches zimmer gegeben
ich schicke gleich jemanden vorbei sie
bekommen ein anderes zimmer
gefällt dir das zimmer jetzt wir haben
sogar als entschuldigung für den fehler
ein upgrade bekommen
gefällt dir das zimmer jetzt wir haben
sogar als entschuldigung für den fehler
ein upgrade bekommen
das bett ist jetzt größer und das zimmer
hat sogar eine badewanne und nicht nur
eine dusche
das bett ist jetzt größer und das zimmer
hat sogar eine badewanne und nicht nur
eine dusche
ja jetzt bin ich zufrieden kommt begehen
in die stadt
ich will etwas essen ich sterbe vor
hunger
[Musik]
ja jetzt bin ich zufrieden kaum begehren
in die stadt
ich will etwas essen ich sterbe vor
hunger
[Musik]
entschuldigung können sie uns ein gutes
restaurant interim quälen entschuldigung
können sie uns ein gutes restaurant in
der nähe empfehlen natürlich natürlich
wenn sie das hotel verlassen gehen sie
gleich rechts
gleich rechts dann gehen sie geradeaus
bis zur nächsten kreuzung
dann gehen sie geradeaus bis zur
nächsten kreuzung
dann nach links dann nach links nach
circa 100 metern gehen sie am supermarkt
vorbei und kommen zu einem kiosk
nach circa 100 metern gehen sie am
supermarkt vorbei und kommen zu einem
kiosk
das restaurant ist auf der anderen
straßenseite des kiosks das restaurant
ist auf der anderen straßenseite des
kiosks
[Musik]
hat mir geschmeckt der tintenfisch war
ausgezeichnet
essen hat mir geschmeckt der tintenfisch
war ausgezeichnet
beim fisch war auch sehr lecker
ja mein fisch war auch sehr lecker
komm wir gehen jetzt an den strand ich
möchte heute noch ins meer springen
ich miete zwei liegestühle einem moment
ich miete zwei liegestühle einen moment
entschuldigen sie was kosten zwei
liegestühle und einen sonnenschirm
für die liegestühle je fünf euro und für
den sonnenschirm acht das macht 18 euro
biete für die liegestühle je fünf euro
und für den sonnenschirm acht das macht
18 euro bitte
aber das ist der preis für einen ganzen
tag jetzt ist schon 16 uhr
also gut zehn euro also gut zehn euro
das wasser ist herrlich endlich ferien
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video